- So for the majority of my life,
I struggled to go to the gym consistently,
even though the gym has
always been a part of my life
to some degree.
I grew up playing hockey
and all my brothers played
hockey and went to the gym.
So going to the gym was
always the right thing to do.
But I could never stay consistent.
Even into university,
sometimes I'd go two
weeks straight at the gym
and then take a month off.
I'd try to get into a
groove and hype myself up,
and I really wanted to look like Thor.
And then I lost my hair.
The whole point of this
story is to let you know
that if you relate to this,
I've been in that exact same place.
But I've managed in recent years
to develop a tremendous
consistency at the gym.
And it takes me a lot
less effort to get there
than it previously ever has.
And I can credit this a lot
to a particular mindset I've adopted
when it comes to doing things
that I find difficult or boring,
and sort of tricking my brain
into liking these things.
I've also been able to apply this strategy
to other areas of my life.
Most specifically to reading
books and editing videos.
Essentially what I did is I
stopped generating motivation
by thinking about an end goal,
and instead I learned
to enjoy the process.
So first of all, what's wrong
with visualizing an end goal?
Why not use this image of this beach body
or a Greek god physique
as motivation to work out?
Well, the main problem
you'll face is the fact
that there is a huge disparity
between what it feels like
to fantasize about this Greek god physique
and what it feels like to actually be
at the gym pushing heavy weights.
They're are completely
different sensation.
Fantasizing about having an
awesome body feels awesome.
It puts you in this sort of La La Land
where you're just walking around
as this imaginary version of yourself.
Actually going to the gym,
it's strenuous, it's sweaty.
And it's often really boring,
especially if you're doing
cardio on a treadmill.
It's the most boring thing
I've ever encountered in my life.
That's the first problem.
The second problem that you face
when you try to generate your motivation
from this ideal image of yourself
is that it will always be a moving target.
No matter how much you fantasize
about this perfect version of yourself,
you will never feel like you have arrived.
And even if you were to
hypothetically arrive at this goal,
there's something called entropy.
Stagnation breeds destruction.
If you just sit on your winnings,
everything will fall apart.
You need to keep moving.
You have to love the daily discipline
of going to battle every single day
and finding pleasure and
fulfillment in the thing,
in the present moment for its own sake.
If you're able to do this,
then that's the happy place.
The thing itself will
generate its own motivation
as you do it.
And you can become fully immersed
in the activity you're doing.
So am I saying it's bad
to have goals in general?
Not at all.
Goals are really good
for creating direction.
Having an ideal is sort
of like having a compass.
It's leading you in the right direction.
You should take a glance
at it for reference,
but in the day-to-day struggle
of actually doing the thing,
it's not what you should be focusing on.
So now that we know why
it's kind of unhelpful
to always think about this end goal,
now you're probably thinking,
how do I learn to enjoy and
embrace difficult things
and have it be an
integrated part of my life?
So there are two things that
really helped me do that.
Number one is more of a mindset shift
and it's more inner work.
And number two is more of a
practical, strategic thing
that you do to yourself.
So number one is to operate
from an abundance mindset
rather than a scarcity mindset.
When you think to yourself,
"I need to go get jacked,"
do you think that's an abundance mindset
or a scarcity mindset?
- [Child] Ready?
Begin.
(whimsical music)
- That is a scarcity mindset
because you need to go get something.
And that applies that you
don't already have it.
When you say I need to go to the gym
because I need to go get jacked,
you're subconsciously saying to yourself
that's because I'm not jacked yet.
Which also implies to yourself
that you're not jacked.
And as I've mentioned in previous videos,
human beings have an innate sense
of wanting to stay
intellectually consistent.
Whatever you think your identity is,
you will operate accordingly.
So if you are constantly telling yourself
that you are not jacked,
what do not jacked people do?
They don't go to the gym.
When you look at it that way,
going to the gym will always be something
that's outside of yourself.
It's something that's unnatural for you.
Why would you go to the
gym if you're not jacked?
So am I saying you should
do some woo-woo thing
and pretend that you're
jacked all of a sudden?
Like force yourself to know
that you are in fact a giant beast?
That's not what I'm saying
because that's not true.
Instead, try reminding yourself
that the reason why you
want to go to the gym
is because you're an active person,
and going to the gym is something
that is important to you.
Your health is important to you.
So since you're an active person,
going to the gym is just something you do.
That gets rid of a ton of
mental resistance in the way
of actually going to the gym.
You can use this exact same
method for reading books.
If you're constantly telling yourself,
oh, I have to go read
books to get smarter.
Oh, I have to go read a book now.
Obviously you're not
gonna have a good time
while you're doing it.
But if you identify as somebody
who enjoys reading books,
it's something that you like doing,
it's just a part of who you are,
then you're way more likely
to actually follow through with doing it.
And if you think this is
just some woo-woo crap,
this is how some of
the greatest musicians,
athletes, and performers operate.
Take John Mayer for example.
I was just watching one of
his Instagram live videos
where he was jamming
out to blues backtracks
and he was having the time of his life.
And he said on the actual livestream.
- Nothing's more fun in this lifetime
going out to dinner and coming home
and picking up a guitar
and just practicing.
Just play.
I don't even call it practicing.
- Because even the word practice implies
that you're only doing it to
achieve some sort of outcome.
But if you're playing,
you're just enjoying it for what it is.
- So when I'm playing for you,
I'm like, I'm kind of
doing what I do at home
which is repeat the same
stuff over and over again
'cause it feels really.
- This next tip is a
little bit more practical
and a little less theoretical.
And that is to utilize habit-bunching.
And that is when you pair
an already existing habit
that you are used to doing
with one that you're trying to work on.
So for instance, I'm a sucker
for a great cup of coffee.
I have one in the morning and
one in the early afternoon.
I really enjoy the taste of coffee
and I look forward to
it every single time.
Do I have an addiction?
Yes, but I can leverage
this filthy habit of mine
into working on another habit.
A great one to pair with a
coffee addiction is reading.
And that's exactly how I
started reading more books.
Every single morning
next to my coffee maker,
I placed the book that I
wanted to read next to it
so that when I made my coffee,
I knew to pick up the book
and I could only drink the coffee
if I was reading the book the
entire time I was drinking it.
Done.
And the crazy thing about this
is eventually you just start
getting used to reading
whether you have coffee or not.
The action of opening
up a book and reading
becomes a lot more natural.
But it'll become something
very pleasant to you.
That's so much better than reading
for the end goal of becoming smarter.
What is getting smarter even feel like?
It doesn't feel like anything.
It's not like in "The Matrix"
where they download kung fu onto Neo,
all of a sudden you just feel it.
Habit-bunching also works really well
when you're trying to develop a gym habit.
If you have an album
that you are currently in
the habit of listening to,
and you crave the sound
of Post Malone's beautiful,
sweet, silky melodies,
then you should leverage that.
Allow yourself to listen to Post Malone,
but only when you're at the gym.
This is one of the main ways I started
to become consistent at the gym.
I had this Migos album that
would pump me up so much.
Even though I'm looking back on it now,
it's not even good music at all.
And just like drinking coffee and reading,
once you start using habit-bunching
to develop a positive association
with the habit you're trying to work on,
then your entire mindset
towards that thing shifts.
Pretty soon you will just
like going to the gym
because of the way it makes you feel.
And realize that it's less about the music
that's actually making you feel so good,
and it's more about the endorphins
of pushing heavy weight
and getting stronger.
So to summarize,
stop generating your motivation
on a day-to-day basis
by fantasizing about some sort of end goal
that you're never going to arrive at.
Instead, use the
appropriate mindset shifts
and the habit-bunching tool
and whatever other tools
at your disposal you have
to help you love the process
and help you love doing these
things for their own sake.
Huge shout-out to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning platform
with thousands of classes
covering dozens of topics.
Everything from
photography to productivity
to learning how the stock market works.
Which is actually the exact topic
that I've sunk my teeth
into recently on Skillshare.
As I build my business and
start making more money,
I know that it's only a matter of time
before I start investing.
Unfortunately, I know pretty much nothing
about the stock market and
it's always been something
that I really wanted to learn more about.
Which obviously if I'm gonna
invest in the stock market,
I would wanna know what I'm doing first.
Luckily there's this class
that I discovered on Skillshare
by a guy named Business Casual.
And he has two classes
on just an introduction
to how the stock market works
and how all the different
elements come into play,
and I feel my mind expanding already.
Pretty soon, I'm gonna be like
Eddie Morra from Limitless
and just start making
millions of dollars overnight.
Skillshare is offering
Better Ideas' viewers
two months completely free
of a premium membership
if you use the link in the description.
Which means right now, absolutely free,
you can check out Business Casual's class
on the stock market
and learn as much as
I'm learning right now.
After your free trial expires,
Skillshare is actually
still very affordable.
If you sign up for the annual membership,
your monthly hit is less than $10 a month.
So once again, hit the
link in the description
to get two months of Skillshare
premium absolutely free.
If you like this video,
make sure to hit Like
because when you hit Like,
the algorithm blesses me
with shoving this video in
front of other people's faces.
This will be especially helpful
if somebody is struggling
to go to the gym,
and my tips in this video
helped them randomly
'cause my face popped
up on their homepage.
If you're lurking here,
consider subscribing and
hitting the bell icon
so you don't miss when I make new videos.
Also, our notification squad is growing.
Last time I checked, it was over 20,000,
which means over 20,000
people get notified,
actually get a pop-up notification
when I upload a new video.
And if you're part of
the notification squad,
there's a way higher chance
that I can actually
respond to your comments.
I can heart your comments.
I can pin your comments.
Really exciting things
happening on the channel.
I'll actually be uploading next week,
based on "Atomic Habits" by James Clear.
But that's all for today.
Thank you for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.
(relaxed music)